thank you
[Music]
all right so this thing is going around
right now and it has a lot of people
feeling many different emotions
um I even asked the JK followers on the
Instagram we did a poll to see who
thinks this is racist and who thinks
it's fine and it's almost split right
down the middle so you guys let me know
um simulu went to a game
no I know what this is I know what this
is and the Jumbotron showed the simulu
look like and they just pointed it at a
random age
it's fun you funny dude like look at the
guy look at the guy
look-alikes they always don't Matt yeah
that's that's the most popular uh
response is that they do it to everyone
they do that all the time everybody
right but it's funny because see who
reposted this it was not happy about it
people who reposted this and said I had
a fun time but this wasn't cool bro the
kid is looking at the screen he's like I
look like that you know like
Avenger now dude that's the other side I
I look like [__] Shang Chi thanks for
saying that that's the other thing uh
simu's response was like I don't look
like him is that is that how people are
taking it as like I think he I think he
knows he doesn't look like him but I
think what he's saying is it's like it's
like pick a random Asian guy and that
looks like you saw that picture I
thought that was Freddie Wong
but can I say something too though yeah
yeah have you guys been to Disneyland
like the new side of this like The
Avengers yeah yeah they got like an
Asian dude walking around playing and
like to be fair he's supposed to look
like him but he doesn't look anything
like him right he's just another Asian
Star-Lord it's just a random white guy
when he is dressed up he definitely
looks a lot more like him than 31
definitely that's the thing that the
thing you said though is is really good
I'm glad you said uh how does that kid
feel yeah what about him that kind of
sucks that he dip he's like really
dunking on that kid too and also she's
on sorry SEMA was on another level now
like he's on he's a [__] action
figure bro like he's the face for a lot
of people to be like oh you are the man
what that is true like you're the
standard you're you're just like
Chadwick to a lot of people's eyes and
he sells stock photos back that's what
I'm saying
so what's that what is it like people
think it's racist because they just
found another random Asian guy in the
crowd so people it's racist because it
perpetuates that thing of like okay just
not being able to tell Asians apart and
just basically pointing it at some
assuming Asian kids it's acceptably
hilarious racism look bro everybody
there's a spectrum to this [__] you know
you can't be [__] cookie cut and
clean everything's [__] perfectly not
racist or racist right they got Vin
Diesel right and they go to a bald guy
exactly like it's like it's part of the
bit like it's it doesn't matter you know
it's not that big of a deal you think
they're more careful with this about
other races than Asians I I do think
that this place I do think that simu and
shangshi specifically in this generation
though like because he maybe also has to
he feels that he has to hold that flag
of representation yeah in in a time
frame that is very sensitive and like
hyper like focused on certain things
like that I think it push puts him in a
position where like it's not so easy to
just be like ah you know that's funny he
might have to say something he might
feel like compelled to speak at the
moment a teachable moment yeah so I can
I can maybe see that it's got to be
tougher for him that's 11. but it's
funny as [__] dude but like if a picture
of simu had glasses then they could go
to that guy but that guy really doesn't
look anything but whatever no other
Asians in the arena yeah you know
they're like going around and they're
like
wrong campaign to be done dude if you
got no other Asians at the All-Stars but
what if you have to do a celebrity look
like with each one of the players yeah
right because he was at the All-Star
game and then they got to go every
single one for one minute there should
have been a judgment call where some
somebody was like we could pull the plug
on one of the races what what city is
this in supposed to be this is Phoenix
Right Salt Lake City hang on Salt Lake
City
why does it even matter why does it even
matter because that's the type it is
the Salt Lake City if it's in Utah Utah
yeah is there that many Asian people in
Utah there's got to be Asians in Salt
Lake City there's ages everywhere but
literally
there's a lot of white people in Salt
Lake City that's what I'm saying like
there's way more whites out there okay
listen to this response from a guy named
Ben who got a blue check so he got eight
bucks he said he said I think it's half
funny and half annoying because of the
just disrespectful Asians look like
trope also simu kind of annoying so it's
kind of funny
I grew up I didn't grow up with the hell
of Asians right yeah when I moved to the
sgv I was like damn dude Asians do look
alive
it's true but also you could say that
about most races I think what it is is
if you didn't grow up if you didn't grow
up with them like when you're just in a
new group right and it's like all
Mexican all black you just feel like yo
what the [__] you guys look like one
group of people damn they look like look
at all right look at all the [__]
photos that JK fans and stuff be sending
Ryan to repost they're like you you
can't tell me this isn't Steve right
yeah so it's like photos of people more
me or Nick right yeah the [__] the
guy from the US see the [__] uh roses
Edward that guy's back he'd say I look
like him and I'm like okay [__] I guess
the game wrong half the people they sent
me
Remember When vitalik butaran the
ethereum founder yeah everybody went on
Twitter means and stuff and I was like
this is like [__] Tom Brady on meth
or some [__] yeah you remember that [__]
and he got mad and and no it was going
crazy and then Tom Brady [__] went on
Twitter reposted that and was like Hey
man you're a good looking dude and like
gave him props for you love your stuff
that's cool I think simu could have had
this opportunity you're right he had
this opportunity too instead of being
like yo everything was fun but this
wasn't cool that you made this guy look
like me I mean look at this fool you're
dunking on this floor yeah you're done
it kind of feels like you compare me to
this yeah he could yeah just found my
next Double yeah stunt double like that
could have been an opportunity to to
clown you could he could have clowned on
the situation and clown on the racism
while still putting our people up in
that way it does feel a bit insecure
when you're like I'm being compared to
that instead of like yo we're a team
yeah we're a [__] team you know
you're a kid bro you know yeah like
Kevin feige signed this [__] up
you know what I mean like could have
been ways to clown on this expression
it's pretty funny though it's like what
yeah he's like Starry Eyed man yeah man
half the people that JK Finn sent me are
Indian they don't even Filipino
they say you look like a bunch of
Indians yeah they sent me hella Indian
people or Bollywood at them you never
repost them you only repost ours yeah
what the [__] dude conspiracy right
because it makes those Indie guys look
bad
oh I get it like I think it's great I
think it's funny like I mean that's
that's another thing it's like if you
grew up never really seeing this as an
issue and it was always a joke growing
up yeah seeing it as an adult you're
like that's not bad you know whatever I
think everyone gets jokes bro yeah at
the end of the day everyone gets joked
on and that's it has to be a whatever
guy does this change the situation if
the guy operating the camera was Asian
it's funnier to find out
open a generation where Asians weren't
even on the radar this to me is cool
right yeah like like they wouldn't even
be able to pull up an actor they could
show that's a conversation it would just
either be a white celebrity look-alike
or a black celebrity look like or maybe
a Hispanic one like the fact that we
even have one that's cool the fact that
we have a whole movie based on an Asian
like a Chinese superhero is crazy and it
that it did well and we only got like
very very few so it's kind of like we
got to be forgiving like everybody look
like shauncey right because we only got
like one shot sheet we don't have like
60 different [__] Asian superheroes
for this it was Bruce Lee yeah and then
whether you were a fat [__] Asian or
a skinny ass asian yeah or bald it
doesn't matter everyone calls you Bruce
Lee whereas if if I'm I'm obviously
Asian if I just see a black person on TV
I'm like hey that kind of looked like
Michael Jordan I can see how that's kind
of racist like this is a [__] [__]
up people out there you know what I'm
saying that's you didn't have to say
that yeah
you could be Eddie Murphy you could be
you could be Holyfield but you know it
would be a little bit more
understandably racist if we did that
because again there's like there's like
50 different types of you know what I
mean like black celebrities that we are
so iconic that we could be like you
can't say this just looks like generic
this right but we only got two or three
Asian guys out there of course
everybody's gonna fall under one of them
Shang Chi and Glenn from Walking Dead
yeah and Bobby Lee and Bobby Lee yeah
which at the end of the day I can
understand how all of them look the same
in some weird way but who's yeah yeah
it doesn't also help that everybody in
entertainment is Korean so that
everyone's just thinking Asians look
like Koreans or we're all Korean you
know or we're all in physical 100.
it's not even as bad as when like Samuel
Jackson was on that Morning Show and the
broadcaster thought he was Lord's
Fishburne
someone else this is just like relating
to things right and that's part of the
joke when jokoy did that when he was
like Lawrence L fishberg
yeah yeah that's like this isn't to me
this is almost like a more tame thing
like at least there's someone they can
show at all like that's dope no now
shimu is included in the same thing that
all the other races and all the other
actors are now we get to be in the game
he's the punchline because it's like he
is the standard now he's the Asian
standard in America's eyes which is a
big [__] deal dude do you think Bruce
Lee would speak up if they did that to
some other random kid in the crowd Bruce
Lee would be like he might know
he wants people like that he write a
script though about it and then you
[__] make a movie and whoop every
white person's ass
dude and there were a bunch of fake
Bruce Lee's already making movies
exactly exactly exactly I think it's a
compliment in a lot of ways yeah for
sure again I I like seeing in general I
think his back is in a different corner
and he's got to be the first but that I
would love for him to do better I would
I would love for him to do better
because there's so few of them is all
you know what I mean what you said
though that's true he could have like
done a big up for this kid yeah yeah but
instead he just said not cool I don't
really like this [__] and he's
not wrong he's not wrong it's just funny
yeah he it really does say he just said
I had a great time but this wasn't cool
[Music]
mm-hmm